stock in the electric car electronic car
company Tesla suffered its worst day in
two years Friday closing down almost 9%
in a single session the plunge follows
controversies surrounding company
founder and CEO Elon Musk some of which
were detailed in an extensive New York
Times article Thursday and then there's
the recent tweet by musk that boosted
company stock but also drew the
attention of federal regulators here to
talk about it all is max chaff c'n he
covers technology for Bloomberg
Businessweek max good morning morning
well let's start with that tweet which
musk says he sent while he was driving
talking about wanting to take his
company private yeah it never a good
sign when you tweet while driving and
it's particularly true if the thing
you're tweeting about is the largest
buyout in you know corporate history
which that was this was a crazy story
when it happened just because the the
idea of musk taking Tesla private would
have been you know a big deal as I said
biggest buyout what made it you know
even crazier is the fact that it
appeared that he basically didn't have
any money to do it which is fine like if
you or I say oh I'd like to buy you know
that car but you know he has investors
the SEC is now involved and it's become
this huge story that is really
distracting from you know what had been
the story which was they were trying to
make these cars as quickly as we also
didn't bother discussing this with his
board apparently no and that's what we
learned in the time story that that he
hadn't you know run it by the board
it's not even clear how hard he thought
about it which is you know it's
particularly strange I mean yeah one of
the the jump out moments for me and
reading that Times article was that for
years they've been trying to find a CEO
you know how is that search going has it
intensified because of that article even
at this point well so we don't really
know how the board is taking this you
have to think when when a CEO does
something you know this crazy that
they're gonna probably intensify their
search for outside talent the the big
story with Tesla for years has been that
Elon Musk is this kind of brilliant
engineer a bit of a micromanager and
he's been sort of stretched very thin
because he also runs a rocket company
SpaceX which is you know right now you
know looking
more stable than Tesla and they just
haven't been able to find anybody to
take that role either a CEO or CEO Oh in
The Times article must brought up the
idea that they had tried to recruit
Sheryl Sandberg you know it's sort of
hard to see why Sheryl Sandberg who CEO
of Facebook would want to take that job
Facebook is a much bigger company it's a
more stable company right now and it's
also the kind of situation where you'd
imagine Sheryl Sandberg kind of wants to
be CEO of a company not somebody's
number two max is somebody who covers
Elon Musk an Tesla how surprising was it
to you that he opened up about the
personal toll that all of this has taken
the exhaustion and he talked about his
personal life as well one of the things
that's made this man so amazing fun to
write about and I think part of the
appeal for Tesla owners Tesla investors
is that he's more human than your
average you know corporate executive
he's he's sort of you know speaks from
the heart to some extent that said when
somebody talks about you know being so
overworked that they're you know sort of
not fully in control he spent his whole
birthday at the office 24 hours yeah and
and he's always been you know somebody
who works very hard but but it really
feels like he's reached you know some
kind of you know breaking point I mean
there was a lot of pain in that
interview and as I said he's always been
somebody who's been out there you know
sort of always willing to say things
that are a little bit crazy and it's
part of the appeal but but it feels like
maybe he's gone a little bit too far
this time all right max Jeff gonna
Bloomberg thanks so much for being with
us